so do you think if you're hanging out
with powerful people in the one day like
you're trying to get to the top someone
sends like a kid to your hotel room like
yes
yes yeah you're like that's not the
reaction that I thought
[Music]
so you guys been hearing about all these
crypto billionaires who are like
dropping like flies all of a sudden
isn't that scary well you mean like just
like like dying in mysterious the plan
is in effect like drowning helicopter
crash oh no [__] people getting
assassinated there's been three of them
in the last like two or three months or
something so who has their crypto Keys
that's a good question by the way no we
don't want to follow the money yet let's
just talk about how they died so it
really was a what are the three deaths
but what I heard recently is if if you
were in crypto you're just an FTX and
then you got wrecked oh really yeah
that's what everyone says there's a
Russian dude was there like a Russian
dude Russian billionaire he died in the
helicopter accident right there was the
cat who died in the water
um after after basically his name is
Nikolai mushigan are they all Russians
that are dying that sounds like a
[__] hell Russian to me yeah um he
was early developer of maker Dow which
is huge everyone's heard yeah um he it's
the largest default bipol in crypto and
he basically puts up
a message saying hey um on Twitter he
says ca and Mossad and pedo Elite are
running some kind of sex trafficking
entrapment blackmail ring out of Puerto
Rico and Caribbean islands they're going
to frame me with a laptop planted by my
ex-girlfriend who was a spy they will
torture me to death and then he gets
found later on that day
um washed ashore
oh [__] that's [__] up yeah but
they're like why would we pinch some
pedophile thing on you when we can just
kill you
that's what everyone's he posted that on
Twitter he posted on Twitter does he
have a check mark is it a blue check
mark uh he did not have a Bluetooth he
didn't paid eight dollars
no he has he had a blue checkpoint I
think with all that money he didn't pay
the eight dollars I think he I think he
paid yet was there was there anything uh
suspicious about the helicopter one
because that one obviously suspicious
this one just happened right what
happened the drowning so this guy named
um oh God the chai islapped hair on I
don't [__] know
that's not bad though he's kind of cute
are they all in Russian yeah founder of
Forex Club head of libertex group I
don't know either Forex club they're all
Russian companies okay so he he died in
a helicopter crash in southeast France
he was 53 years old he was the only
passenger in the aircraft piloted by a
35 year old French national who was also
killed I'm surprised that a 53 year
old's in crypto I know right usually
they're all [__] haters usually they
can't even work their [__] phone
exactly and they're like can you can you
teach me how hey how do I so like if I
lose my ledger did I lose all my crypto
house because all my cryptos are on The
Ledger huh
yeah dude don't step on your Ledger out
there it does and then who's the third
one
um there's a there's more than three bro
um whoa yeah give me one sec do you
think it's part of some sort of like
strategic elimination like a John Wick
style operation they just for crypto
because I feel like the incentive would
be for the government right like if
crypto is supposed to be decentralized
and then if the government feels like
they're losing power it's in their best
interest to get rid of these guys that
are the heavy players in this game I
don't know so there's another cat um his
name's tiantan kulander God damn it
helps when you go like this as you say
yeah thank you
um co-founder of digital asset uh
company Amber group died in his sleep
November 23rd 2022. well it's because
he's just had a heart attack from seeing
the crash
um did he sleep yeah okay
[Music]
they say that that guy is only like 30
something right yeah he's a young guy he
looks like this I mean he's [__] so a
lot of stress yeah you're like what the
[__] that guy's dirty something with a
heart attack dude starting to sleep I
don't know that sounds like a poisoning
yeah no anything we don't know that's
the crazy thing everyone in this in one
industry and they're all billionaires uh
or like up there in these like there's
definitely
two billionaire so far that I named I
think the maker guy I don't know if he's
a billionaire but they're all Heavy
money guys heavy Big Time Players for
sure that's how you know we're not dead
that's goddamn right nobody they
actually Keep Us Alive matter of fact
more alive than ever
they're making us eat healthier things
we're having Health spikes no so the guy
I was just talking about who I just
showed you a picture of his company's
value to 3 billion so major hitters yeah
major major hitter the CIA delivers
salads for us because they're like
please live longer yeah no tomatoes the
acidity
stay away from the nightshades yeah
uh what do you think's going on BART
I don't know mentioned this yesterday
and you you had some fun I was thinking
I was thinking if this is if they're all
rushing or if they're all Russian based
it could be like they just feel like
they're being threatened by power taken
away from the government so it'd be in
their best interest to like oh yeah
snipe pickles out and then yeah and then
like [__] consolidate maybe Russia
needs money so they gotta extract as
much as they can so they can fight the
war in Ukraine so it's not a terrible uh
Theory it's kind of got a good idea I'm
not bad I heard all the research you
guys are smart you guys get it huh I
didn't even think not that smart we got
wrecked pretty hard they'll be able to
do it like that kill a guy and then take
his crypto maybe I don't know that it's
that maybe it's what Bert's saying is
that they're trying to centralize more
of the controls we don't need the money
we just need these Power Players out of
power yeah we need them to stop taking
up market share maybe because now if
they have like billions of Bitcoin
Bitcoin is only useful if people are
using it but if it's just dead Bitcoin
that's never being traded like oh okay
cool that's just forever I don't have to
account for that but technically that
makes bitcoin's value go up if there's
still demand for Bitcoin because there's
more Bitcoin locked up in these debt
accounts but you can't you can't break
sha 256 encryptions you can't just like
Brute Force attack all these old wallets
one day you probably will be able to but
then they'll have to update the way that
they protect
um Bitcoin wallets with atomic security
you said a lot of numbers now dude well
no so Atomic Computing right everyone's
afraid of of that brute forcing the
encryption that Bitcoin uses on these
walls that's why you can like not your
keys not your crypto you're protecting
your crypto by putting it on like a
ledger or a treasure wallet right
because you can't Brute Force those
things would you say the the coding was
sha-256 encryption yeah that's what got
me tripped up that's what that but
that's what the people are concerned if
Atomic Computing happens that could be
Brute Force yeah we're concerned about
that and then all these models well then
all these wallets including the Satoshi
wallets which have like billions of
dollars worth of bitcoin in there and
then all of a sudden all that enter
circulating Supply and tries to file you
down yep not my ship not my Sheba coins
wait I feel like we kind of nonchalantly
just glazed over that tweet can you read
that tweet one more time before that guy
got yeah it's pretty [__] hard
absolutely he's like gonna blow the
cover off a bunch of pedal [__]
and then he just passed away let me
retweets it again
that shit's crazy who retweeted it yeah
exactly that's what we gotta really ask
I feel like with all the stuff we have
going on in this world this is like the
closest we've gotten to like pulling
back the curtains but we're still not
there and I feel like we just need like
somehow if we could just really see
maybe it's through Maxwell or through
something but there's definitely like
some sort of like puppet show that we're
like I think we finally see who's
playing everything but we can't CIA and
musad and pedo Elite are running some
kind of sex trafficking entrapment
blackmail ring out of Puerto Rico and
Caribbean islands they're going to frame
you with a laptop planted by my
ex-girlfriend who owns a spy they will
torture me to death then later on that
day his body is recovered shows no vital
signs the police are saying nothing
about a homicide or it's not considered
a homicide like he drank too many
monetizing drones do you think this is
related to some Epstein stuff because
it's all the same players right yeah
CIA right Island kids do I think that
nah dude me neither none of us ever
think that we just report what other
people think that's exactly right yeah I
don't I want to stay out of this frankly
yeah but it's not like I have billions
of dollars to get killed over I'm close
you as well to even just be like in the
category of description as pedo Elite
yeah like yeah who's the pedal Elite we
need to because I think there's an elite
and then there's a pedal Elite yeah
that's the elite elite I heard that they
all do that [__] so they have dirt on
each other and they can trust each other
that way that's the entrapment right
that's the that's the um Epstein model
is what they say right is that he was
filming all that happening at the island
and then using that as blackmail on huge
players so do you think if you're
hanging out with powerful people in the
one day like you're trying to get to the
top someone sends like a kid to your
hotel room like yes I made it yeah
you're like oh that's not the reaction
that I thought well if you're trying to
get to the top but you would never do it
though you wouldn't do it but you're
like flattered that like but if you're
trying to get to that so I thought that
counts kind of thing and then I have to
sit that poor kid down and be like I'm
sorry I'm not interested in it I
appreciate the nomination yeah yeah I'm
gonna sit this one out I don't want you
to feel rejected yeah I rejected this I
want to hold my status so you just sit
here we don't have to talk to each other
or anything I just sit there for the
hour you want something to eat like that
what's a room service I'm like a grilled
cheese sandwich or something mac and
cheese is really good here leave after
hey can we get some dino nuggets over
here for me what do you want
oh you can order for the kids menu huh
oh my god get some crayons or something
what a statement oh yeah you can do a
maze in there if you want the word
search you guys gave us the thing
there's no crayons imagine just so
whoever comes to your door how old are
you ah man it's like an adult like they
send a prostitute a 21 year old [__]
prostitute get out of here that's what
they that's what they think of me yeah
50 years
21. it's like gonna go watch when you
retire you're like that's [__] it I
thought I was finally gonna be a [__]
88th Mason
he's like you're 18 huh [__] what do I
have to do for these [__] people
I don't want to just be elite I gave my
life for this you're like how 18.
that's disgusting Anthony that's what
Joe said oh Joe said that I just repeat
the opinions of others
[Music]